thank you
people have long reiterated that anime
is a feel-good genre sure we can't
generalize it all and there are some
really Bleak and cynical ones out there
but generally speaking it's like most
anime shows us an idealized version of
what could have been fantasy world or
otherwise a lot of it especially those
in the Shonen or rom-com genre often
talk about believing in yourself
following your dreams or staying true to
your feelings and then there are those
shows that give a slightly different
type of satisfaction one that appeals to
our feelings of actually being more than
what we show or what people think we are
so today I'm going to be having a
shorter and more relaxed list giving
recommendations on my favorite shows
where the main character pretends to be
weak or stays low-key but is actually
super strong let's begin with a cult
classic rock no yusha
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I'm not sure if cult classic would be an
app description but Rocca is one of
those mildly popular shows back when it
was airing it didn't set the world on
fire like its seasonal peer Overlord but
it's still quite the Intriguing mystery
that garnered its fair share of fans six
Heroes get summoned but seven arrive
there's obviously a traitor Among Us and
of course the suspicion points towards
our main character adlet Maya and it's
up to him and his skills to survive and
expose the real traitor in the case of
the protagonist it's an interesting case
I mean Adler does carry the moniker of
being the strongest man in the world
however he's also the type of person who
prefers to carry himself lightly
defining himself as an ordinary person
as opposed to the other Heroes and their
grandiose oh and he fights rather
strategically too claiming that being
the strongest means being the most
creative and flexible In the Heat of the
battle whether you agree with him or not
that's up to you but rock on no yusha
remains a fun blast from the past that
you can still enjoy in the modern era
believe that
foreign
[Music]
case in a world where magicians in the
top school get categorized into blooms
the overachievers and weeds The
Underachievers our protagonist datsuya
got classified in the latter yeah the
way the tests categorized him was to put
him in the midst of The Underdogs those
deemed to have deficiency in terms of
magical skills which is hilarious in
hindsight but it's not like tatsuya
cares true he doesn't outright try hard
to pretend to be weak but he does keep
up a humble profile despite us fans
knowing he's pretty much magical world
God or something in the end I think
that's the point of mahoka that's one of
the key themes that binds the whole
series together and it's part of what
made the series so popular back in the
day you can follow that two years
exploits with his classmates and sister
and see how he proves the world's
systems wrong with each passing moment
in mahoka it's got two seasons a movie
and a flashback OVA so that's a lot of
content to consume
those are some cool anime but how about
now we have some wacky rom-com hijinks
for a break welcoming today's sponsors
odome domain odome domain is a visual
novel published by shiravune who you may
remember from uttarumono it's newly
released on Steam and it's a handful you
get to follow the story of Minato an
orphan boy who through circumstances
finds himself in an all-girls school so
there's only one thing left for him to
do learn to cross-dress and blend in
with the princesses all the while
fostering bonds with them and learning
what they really are like when the
curtains are down we've got a great cast
of girls to work with here too meet
Hinata Yuzu and kazari all girls who
come with a lot of fun quirks along with
Minato and his impeccable skill in
cross-dressing and blending in is one of
the girls you just know there's some
comedy waiting around every corner
although my domain is a game that I
appreciated more the longer I played it
and learned about the characters people
back then thought so too as it bagged
home a couple of awards from as far back
as 2016. if you're interested then don't
hesitate to fall via Twitter and check
the game out for yourself on his steam
page or its main website all links are
down there in the description box for
you in the overall scheme of things
however I do think that Sawyer pales in
overpoweredness compared to Wang Ling of
daily life of the immortal King
if you've not yet acclimated to the
countless Chinese conservation novels
out there on the internet daily life of
the immortal King might be a good
starting point it's got three seasons
and it's pretty much all the general
tropes and plot points you need to
experience to determine if the genre is
for you or not anyway back to one League
he actively decides to pursue a plain
everyday life as a teen after all
traveling those Realms can take a real
toll on a body and once you've reached
that Pinnacle of world ending power the
first thing you'd want to do is just be
plain old you unfortunately stuff like
that never happens in anime thus he must
once again take the Mansion of being the
strongest Immortal being in the world to
protect those who treasured senior high
school has never been this eventful for
the strongest genius this world has ever
seen
all right
Wang Ling's not alone in his dilemma and
if you're up for a show with a similar
theme and a different take here's the
disastrous life of psyche k
yle
overpowered but hide their powers
preferring to stay away from the
spotlight while having The Misfortune to
have these super powered foes coming
after them yeah I'm pretty sure Wang
Ling and psychi kuso would hit it up
quite easily after all a shared dilemma
is a strong builder of friendship but
generally speaking if you've gone
familiar with the premise of daily life
you more or less know what you're
getting with psyche K just without the
insane overpowered character that breaks
the scales psyche's got a whole
assortment of powers nonetheless just
not in the same Dimension breaking scale
still I find this show really great due
to its very comedic undertone it feels
like a parody of sorts and psyche ends
up being a really relatable character
not for his powers but for his straight
man gimmick and how he does his internal
monologues his variety of powers also
gets displayed in various levels of
entertaining ways a good takeaway though
is that the anime airs as a series of
shorts at roughly five minutes each so
if you're looking for something fun to
watch in short bursts a show that's easy
to consume while waiting for something
the disastrous life of psychike is well
worth your time
foreign
[Music]
make sure to hit that like button as
well as taking time to subscribe for
more content like this let's shift to
something way more modern now however
with Eminence in Shadow
[Music]
it was one of those shows that came into
the season with a surprising amount of
hype even more surprisingly though it
maintained its hold on the community in
a rather consistent basis yeah we all
know it wouldn't reach the heights of
something like the big guns like
chainsaw man or the sleeper hits like
Bocce The Rock still its fan base
remained pretty loyal and that's because
Eminence and Shadow for me is a very
honest show coming in you know what
you're gonna get and you get it on a
consistent basis the Chutney aspect an
entire selection of girls that you'll
surely find a waifu or two from a plot
that's engaging enough and some cool
action featuring Sid it doesn't feel
pretentious in any way and Sid feels
like the right amount of overpowered
protagonist and awkward kid at heart
with the idiot genius charm he ended up
becoming one of my favorite main
characters in the season mostly owing to
just how cool and edgy his presentation
is like the show doesn't shy away from
the fact that it's just power fantasy in
a different flavor and if you know what
to expect and buy into it Eminence in
Shadow is something you'll definitely
enjoy
last but not least a fan favorite now
one punch man
one punch man it's the anime of 2015 and
for good reason too it takes a lot of
the cliches and tropes we've known from
action anime and gives them a spin
resulting in a parody anime that's one
of the best of what it does also this is
a personal opinion but I felt that one
punch man piggybacked off the superhero
Trend that was picking up steam right
around that era both in the world of
anime and Hollywood still even without
that context I think the one punch man
would have become a very popular show
owing to its excellence in presentation
and a healthy combination of both hype
and dramatic moments at this point I
think that saithama needs no
introduction and the same goes for why
the show is on the list saithama may be
the strongest hero of them all but you
wouldn't have guessed it as one of the
rare people who aren't familiar with one
punch man he doesn't stand out he
doesn't have all those cool and
breathtaking powers and he doesn't carry
himself like the strongest hero in the
world should however only a fool would
underestimate him as one punch literally
is all it takes for scythama to end even
the vilest evildoers the world's ever
seen one punch man did have a second
season and one I think the franchise
peeked in his first season you might
also find the sequel worth a watch
amongst the seven titles which one do
you think is the best is there any other
similar show that you'd like to
recommend I'll be reading the comments
so make sure to give your feedback as
well as possible list suggestions in the
future in the meantime hope you've had
fun watching this video and take time to
check out the channel for more videos
and don't forget to check out odome
domain the links in the description
thanks a lot for watching and I hope to
see you next time